mientras que Estados Unidos ofreció
permiso de residencia y trabajo durante
dos años a los 222 presos políticos
nicaragüenses que fueron liberados y que
llegaron tras ser deportados a la
capital estadounidense el jueves el
gobierno de España ha ido un paso más
allá los excarcelados podrán optar a la
nacionalidad española si así lo desean
esto lo anunció esta mañana el ministro
de asuntos exteriores español José
Manuel Álvarez asegurando que la oferta
se extiende a cualquier otra persona que
esté en situación de privación de
libertad en Nicaragua por razones
políticas en declaraciones a la agencia
de noticias servimedia el canciller
español aseguró que la oferta es
inmediata y que surgió tras conocerse
que el gobierno de Daniel Ortega había
iniciado el proceso de declarar a esas
personas apátridas el trámite que sería
a través de una carta de naturalización
podría hacerse en muy poco tiempo con
este anuncio los 222 liberados podrían
sumarse así a los 61.500 nicaragüenses
que viven en España que es el el país de
Destino de los emigrantes de esta nación
después de Estados Unidos y Costa Rica
Nicaragua por su parte es el décimo país
solicitante de protección internacional
en España una lista que encabezan
Venezuela y Colombia